[Music]
this is Star Talk of things you thought
you knew Edition Chuck is that your
favorite format it's probably no
explainers are my favorite but things
are things you thought you knew is my
second favorite because I am aware
thanks to working with you for almost 12
years that I Don't Know Jack crap yeah I
don't know that is what I have learned
well so thank you all this time we have
spent together is that I don't I used to
think I thought at one point I knew
something I thought I knew something and
then the universe sent a man named Neil
deGrasse Tyson into my life and then the
universe said boy you don't know
[Music]
okay so things you thought you knew is
like a superset of explainers so first
one is gonna be rainbow okay that that
sounds nobody doesn't love rainbows
that's right sounds delightful okay
nobody doesn't love rainbows okay I I
have a quick rainbow story ready I knew
okay a couple they were dating and the
guy was a little high strung and and she
was sort of like normal right and she
pointed we were driving I happened to be
in the car with them and there's a
beautiful rainbow out the window and I
and and the guy was speaking about
something else and I said oh look at the
rainbow and she said oh that's a
beautiful ranga and he says no shut up
I'm talking about something else and I
said what
who doesn't like rainbows and she turned
to him and and two months later they
broke up yeah
he didn't know it but they were already
broken up
so I could see some therapists he knows
the signs that's it buddy let me tell
you
sorry number two the second segment just
gonna be about zero
all right the number zero the number
zero yeah number zero's a number just
get over it right okay yeah you never
think of zero as a number yeah yeah but
it is and we need it it turns out for
most of what we do in mathematics so is
that and the third one is what do Zoom
calls
and Einstein's theory of relativity have
in common all right you've gone too far
I know him I stepped off the ledge it's
just seriously bro you are are over the
cliff oh that's it give it a chance
chuck oh my God let me try
[Laughter]
I don't know how you gonna pull that
rabbit out your head
all right let's get to our first one in
this first segment
so Chuck we're going to talk about
rainbows my eight-year-old daughter
loves rainbows okay well make sure she
listens to this all right so that's cool
yeah so it was not until Isaac Newton my
man that's your boy okay early 1700s he
wrote a book in was 1704 it was just
called Optics one of the rare books that
he actually wrote in English all his
other books were in Latin which was the
the you know well he really was a nerd
okay but in there he figured something
out okay everyone of course had known
about the colors of the rainbow red
orange yellow green blue violet every
okay and people have seen you know
chandelier light will come through the
chandelier and you'd see rainbow colors
come out one side or another
everybody until Newton
presumed that those callers Were Somehow
getting generated inside the chandelier
glass okay inside the Raindrop right
there was some property of the medium
itself
nobody was thinking that pure white
light is composed of those colors oh if
only we could learn that lesson in our
society
[Music]
so imagine if Martin Luther King were
more physics fluent that would have been
a whole different I Have a Dream speech
yeah it would I have a dream
that one day we will recognize the white
black red or brown we're all white
oh
it's okay it's okay
everybody would have tipped their head
and said what it's what we invited this
man
I may not get there with you but we'll
all be white one day
stop
foreign
here's how he did it okay so he puts
white light through a prism
okay and out the other side comes the
colors of the rainbow much as what we
all remember from Pink Floyd's Dark Side
of the Moon album cover one of the best
ever
all right so he then and this is what
makes Newton Newton he said let me take
another prism
and put it upside down next to it oh
okay and this is kind of reverse what
had just happened
and when he did that out the second
prism came white light
okay how did I not hear
and all the time we've been working
together this is the first time I've
ever heard this story yes this is
brilliant yes because in doing so he
proves that it has nothing to do with
the actual medium itself that the light
coming in was merely separated and then
by coming out and going back into
another medium it combines it's the
light it's just the light that's why he
is Isaac Newton and the rest of us
aren't is that how that is brilliant and
it's simple and Brilliant yes yeah
exactly if that's what makes it extra
brilliant is how simple it is so at that
point it's easy to sort of extrapolate
that a rainbow is just sunlight broken
up into those same colors that the prism
did for you right okay so now what's
going on inside a raindrop so sunlight
enters the Raindrop at a particular
angle all right actually comes in at all
angles but only one of those angles will
internally reflect
off the boundary between the Raindrop
and the air
okay this is this is the one of the most
fascinating features of Optics okay so
so in other words if I'm under water and
I let's say I have a laser so we get a
nice sharp point and I point it upwards
not straight up but at an angle at a
slight angle when that laser beam exits
into the air it bends
okay it's bent right it's bent okay okay
you can picture this you can try it
yourself if you have a pocket laser Okay
so
it's easy then to expect that a similar
thing is happening between sunlight and
raindrops that was happening between
your sunlight and your prism so so
but the fun part is the sunlight goes
inside the raindrop
and bounces around a couple of times
before it exits again
and by the time it exits all of those
colors have been separated out from the
white light
and thus you have this participatory
rainbow where all of these dots of uh
all these droplets of water participate
in one coherent rainbow
now the the the the the angle the light
exits
creates a rainbow that you see
okay right okay right you only see what
enters your eye you can't see what
doesn't enter your eye correct right
that makes sense okay by the way that
itself was a discovery from a thousand
years ago
um uh uh IBN Al Haytham was a a Muslim
uh scientist back in the the Golden Age
of Islam he
first to deduce that sight
is not you beaming stuff out of your
eyes it's completely passive your
eyeballs are just sitting there waiting
for light to enter and for your brain to
then make an image this is profound
because before then you had these
Legends like like like uh Medusa yeah
all right how does Medusa work how does
that work well when you look her in the
eyes she turns you to Stone basically
she turns you right into stone because
she's casting whatever from her eyes
from her that's correctly you could only
think that if you have no idea how
Vision Works right or or if you're
creating X-Men but that's interesting
oh he's got yeah he's got his little
visor thing that you can send out the
beams so what that means is all of the
rainbow light
that's coming to you is exiting those
raindrops at the precise angle that
enters your eyeballs okay okay that
means
your rainbow
is unique to you
wow
when if I stand to your left or right or
above doesn't matter if I stand
somewhere else and we're looking at
quote the same rainbow we tell ourselves
we're not
you know what this fact means
I do not okay
every rainbow you have ever seen
has been exactly face on to you Aha and
so I am every rainbow
actually was made just for me just for
you you have never witnessed a rainbow
at an angle angle right
so think about that because if your
Rainbow was a real thing in the sky
I could move to another location and
look at it from a different angle right
if it was an actual thing like anything
else right like a mountain a tree or
whatever like anything else okay
so
if you wanted to go to the base of the
rainbow
you can't
ah because that would be taking a
different angle of view on a thing that
does not really exist as a physical
entity and and now you have just
explained how I have wasted a
significant portion of my life
trying to find that pot of gold
if you're gonna hide a pot of gold put
it at the bottom of a rainbow nobody
would ever find it exactly ever
ever
yeah so so just a little known fact now
the light that's inside the Raindrop
this is like inside baseball here you
ready for this this is go ahead this is
for this is this is Rainbow 201 not 101.
so the light inside the Raindrop right
sends out not only one rainbow but
multiple rainbows but each next one is a
little weaker than the previous one okay
okay okay
and because the second rainbow that
comes out had an extra extra reflection
to it
if you ever see a double
rainbows on the mushrooms
what's that it means you're tripping on
mushrooms
physics yeah sometimes it's actually
just physics nuts and mushrooms yeah
okay that's it so go ahead
the two properties of that second
rainbow is one it's much dimmer than the
first
gotcha it's always there but generally
it's very hard to detect because it's so
dim so it's much dimmer and the sequence
of colors is reversed oh no from the
original
that's okay that is first of all that's
dope secondly who knew so the double
rainbow is kind of like the reverse
rainbow it's a it's an inverted rainbow
to the first rainbow and it's dimmer
there's actually a third and fourth and
fifth they're called the orders of the
rainbow first order second order third
order but they're so dim if if the sky
is bright you just will never see them
and there's a famous YouTube video some
years back uh but I think they just call
it the double rainbow guy he's hiking
yeah that's what I'm saying he's
tripping on mushrooms that guy and he
sees two rainbows and he and he falls
prostrate to the ground uh and said
there is a God
[Music]
and that's how you behave if you don't
know physics right you just think it's a
right it's a it's just physics really
that's all it is it's just physics you
know once again Neil way to ruin
rainbows
I want you to reserve your sense of
wonder
for things for which we still do not
understand
ah and not apply it for things that are
completely understood you know there
will always be a moving Frontier of
science where our area of knowledge
grows
so too does the perimeter of our
ignorance leaving us with no end
of this universe to stand in Wonder as
we give
wow
okay
nothing ain't nothing left to say
nothing left to say that's it that's it
explainer video there you go all about
rainbows
so Chuck we got to take a break when
we'll come back we'll do a little bit
more of this we'll find some other
subject if you're gay sounds great let's
do it okay start talk stuff you thought
you knew will continue
we're back Chuck yeah things you thought
you knew you ready for another one I'm
ready let's do it let's go there and by
the way I picked these based on
how familiar we think we are
about the subject and then throw in some
things that you never knew see that's
the cool thing though because
I mean if we were just going to talk
about like gravitational waves of course
we know we don't know none you know what
I mean like who's an astrophysicist
there's like what 20 of you you know
what I mean you know like seven of you
sitting around you know yeah yeah so
this is not just let me explain stuff
that you can get a Reiki page it's like
no you know cool fun stuff you never
thought no it's the twist The Twist that
gets you man like the inverted rainbow
who knew that the orders of rainbow who
knew that yeah yeah like I mean that's
stuff that you honestly but everybody
knows rainbows so for this segment we're
going to talk about zero
all right here we go again
be honest
you
it's it's this is a this is gonna be
tough for you man
are you ready all right here we go zero
all right so let's do this so zero
is a number
but it wasn't always a number
in fact no one ever imagined
it could be a number
in fact no one even imagined how to
imagine it
why would you right what were numbers
for right who counts nothing right
numbers are for counting right okay how
many chickens do you have three how many
cattle do you have you count things so
nobody had any use
to count zero
it just was not there for most of
civilization this was the case right
even through
the Roman Empire
wow we think of them as highly civilized
the whole cities and hot baths and
armies and if that's equivalent
aqueducts and aqueducts right they were
they're so sophisticated their numbers
were letters
so Roman Empire
they can count they used Roman numerals
right we learn Roman numerals in
elementary school don't we still I think
right and the reason why we learn Roman
numerals is so that we know how to count
Super Bowl games
that is kind of the only application no
one more one other for some movie
sequels true
true that's it true that's it I don't
know any other application okay yeah oh
I know also lowercase Roman numerals are
the page numbers in books before you get
to the actual
uh chapters of the book okay yeah that's
true look at the bottom of the pages
those are usually Roman numerals and
then they restart from from one at the
beginning okay yeah so I don't know if
you've ever thought about this Chuck
uh-huh you can't write zero with Roman
numerals no you can right there is no
symbol for zero
it's not because they didn't come up
with it it's that the concept of zero
was not yet invented wow
so when they made the Julian calendar
that's the one that has a leap day every
four years
and because they knew enough to know
that the calendar needed it
that calendar the Julian calendar which
anchored its starter date on the birth
of Jesus
okay so this obviously came later after
Constantine I I think Constantine
brought Christianity to the Roman Empire
so in the Julian calendar they went from
one BC BC of course stands for before
Christ to A.D one and a d is in Latin
and domini the year of Our Lord one and
there was no year zero in that
transition
so so when would Jesus have been born
all right and you know in the mythical
year between the two he can't be born in
ad1 because that's after and he can't be
born in BC because that's before so
remember so there's a there's an issue
oh I got the answer
it's a miracle okay
well later biblical research would show
that Jesus was probably born closer to
three or four BC and so but the calendar
was already in place so you're stuck
with that there's a mismatch there three
or four year we gotta play this hand we
gotta play this hand bro we gotta plan
okay so now move time forward
going
um
is in the 600 700s I forgot exactly when
uh in India
the great advances in mathematics there
where they even developed the numerals
early versions of the numerals we now
use
okay rather than Roman numerals okay
Roman numerals were letters these are
now sort of symbolic shapes
that would then represent the numbers
and in this effort where was the hint
that maybe you might want a zero in
there
okay okay so we're crawling now before
we can walk but but the seeds are
planted this these new mathematics work
their way to the Middle East
okay and Baghdad specifically a big
trading post from all corners of Europe
and Asia and Africa and there it was
ideas were put across the table that
this is the Golden Age of Islam all
right the major advances were made and
all in in engineering and astronomy and
biology physiology and and and envision
that's where the discovery that uh in in
vision is a passive phenomenon not
active and so all of this is going on
and then the zero was perfected
zero is perfected they call those
numerals Hindu numerals
okay but we today call those numerals
Arabic numerals right yeah okay so so
this is the full tracking there be
because in the Middle East an entire
algebra rose up and arithmetic and
algebra rose up invoking zero and you
have negative numbers and so mathematics
is Off to the Races algebra is one of
very common words in English that has
its roots in Arabic a lot of the AL
words uh Al is the in Arabic yeah Al
Green yeah yeah so so algebra algorithm
right another one alcohol these are all
traceable to that period but all I'm
trying to say the best of which is
alcohol
good going guys there you go wait a way
to do it
so so I'm just saying zero all
just consider how late zero came
in Civilization the Egyptians knew
nothing of zero right the but it's there
and and we've got it and so now what is
this what is this I hear about the
Mayans uh and zero that they somehow had
something to do I don't fully know my
Mayan history other than that their
calendar was they really worshiped Venus
in the sky hello and so the calendar was
sort of Venus based uh the calendar in
ancient Egypt was based on the star
Sirius when I mean I'm talking about the
new year when he started yeah just
completely arbitrary when you say that
here the new year just began you know
completely arbitrary just pick a date
and whatever matters in your culture
call it the beginning of the year it's
not you know and to this day when is the
Chinese New Year it's in like late
January February right right everybody's
got a different starter date and so that
we the Jewish New Year is another new
year that yeah yeah everybody's got
their new year everybody's got their own
New Year the academic calendar has a new
year it's it's September 1st even though
they don't say it it really is that you
know the academic folks come back from
summer vacation children buy their
school supplies that's in a way a New
Year's Day for school
if you want to fast think about it all
right that's right and by the way one
quick thing you got a hundred dollars in
your bank account and you go withdraw a
hundred dollars from the cash machine
and the bank tells you what
um don't do this again man because uh by
the way you think you have a hundred
dollars and you don't okay
that was the elect what you forgot was
the electric bill came through yesterday
before you withdrew the 100. you sound
like this has happened to you Chuck so
here's the thing you you have no money
left in the bank and that's bad
but what's worse is to have negative
money yes in the bank and so this whole
concept of negative numbers arose
and made complete sense once you pass
through zero and now instead of
something coming your way you now owe it
right and so the mathematics began to
mirror Commerce and the needs of
civilization as we move forward because
we're doing much more than just counting
things
you know so this is like the birth of
modern accounting once you find zero
that's when you're able to actually have
you know a Leisure seat that shows you
minus and pluses and all that kind of
yeah it's one of the few places in the
world where it's really good to be in
the black
apparently no other way is it good to be
in the black except on the on the
accounting seat
oh that's great
um so so they can go into negatives and
this keeps going with math and you find
other needs of culture and civilization
and science where whole other branches
of math have to be developed and so this
just went on and on and we got
trigonometry all the stuff that you
thought the teacher was just being angry
with you giving you these assignments
these are entire branches of math the
zero started it all where it gives you
deeper insights into the operations of
nature
absolutely
um wow that's uh that's pretty cool I
mean all this just from from nothing
yeah all this came from nothing and so
in this way nothing means something
right and what's that what's that song
from the 80s nothing from nothing leaves
nothing okay you gotta have something if
you won't be with me nothing from
nothing leaves leaves nothing I think
that's a legit equation I have to think
about that zero minus zero you just
can't start dividing
right by zero because in the end of
dividing by zero and that's that's
illegal
right that said you've broken a law of
the universe or something but
you desire many times right Beetlejuice
shows up
[Laughter]
so Chuck I just want to bring up a bit
up to speed on zero that's all yeah yeah
I gotta tell you I've never been more
impressed with nothing so this is cool
this is very cool so Chuck we gotta take
a quick break but when we come back we
can slip in another stuff you thought
you knew I see are you game I'm totally
gay USB totally game all right we'll be
right back
Chuck we're back yes yeah
all right all right
what the zoom calls
and Einstein's theory of relativity have
in common
um no one knows how either of them
actually work
that's a good answer I'm gonna say
that's gotta be the answer
that's a good that's a good answer so
here you go you ready okay let's do it
uh what we learned what we affirmed in
Einstein's theories of Relativity is
that
space cannot be thought of just as space
time is a fundamental coordinate right
alongside space so that when you ever
want to think about events phenomena
past present future you have to think of
space-time you can't just think of space
where time has separate things and
there's an entire set of equations that
fold the two together that's see now
that's the first part I am so cool with
I like literally get it you know but
when you talk about proving it
mathematically I'm still just gonna be
tight that's all yeah of course it keeps
it keeps moving it keeps working when
the map works it works yeah it works
right okay so
um let us for those who might still be
uncomfortable with the space-time
concept
what you don't know perhaps is that you
live that way there's no other way you
you live it's so intuitive you think
it's complicated but it's easy
so if I say to you Chuck
you ready okay I'd say uh Chuck
uh let's have lunch tomorrow at noon
I would say oh my God as long as you're
paying
that is such a wonderful offer okay
Chuck it's on me let's have lunch
tomorrow at noon what is your next
comment back to me where where you want
to eat what do you want because the time
alone was insufficient
for you for your life and my life to
intersect
time is alone will not make that happen
you also have to give a spatial
coordinate is it the diner on the corner
of you know Hollywood and Vine
at 12 noon so you have a space
coordinate and time coordinates so that
we can both meet
right okay by the way leave it to you to
give me a coordinate where you know I
can't get to
see a diner in the corner of Hollywood
and Vine right yesterday and I go there
tomorrow we were in the same place we
were
but not at the same time oh okay it
doesn't work okay okay let's keep going
you were at the diner yesterday and I'm
at the diner tomorrow we're both in the
same place
but not at the same time right
okay
which which is what I call Neil's
favorite lunch
Chuck yeah you were here yesterday good
okay so now watch so now you're at the
diner in the corner and I'm at with this
works with Starbucks you're in that
Starbucks I'm in a different Starbucks
okay
we're at the same time
but not at the same place
right yes it's the same brand but it's a
different location yeah but it's a
different location yeah okay so you need
to be at the same place and at the same
time for anything to happen where you
have two things that want to coordinate
together right okay all right so how
does this manifest let's go in the
universe and there's an asteroid headed
towards Earth
you could do the Bruce Willis thing and
what
blow it up blow it out of the sky which
it takes a lot of waste and energy or
you can deflect it well how do you
deflect not a good movie
how do you deflect an asteroid so here
it is if you left it alone it will
collide with Earth
which means it will be in the same place
at the same time that Earth is sometime
in the future at some point in the
future okay
so what I can do is I can speed up the
asteroid
oh I love that
you're oh you speed it up then it gets
to that location in my Orbit before I do
exactly
so it's at the we're exists at the same
time but we're not in the same place
that's a whole other way to look at
deflecting an asteroid that's what's
going on when you deflect an asteroid
that's awesome or you could slow it down
then we get to that point before it does
we keep moving and it goes right on by
behind us oh man it's the proverbial
um mental uh exercise that everyone does
when they have a car accident
if only I hadn't forgotten my keys if
only I had left a little bit earlier
I would have never had spot at that time
for exactly for the drunk driver correct
exactly right yeah it's a mental
calculation you do right right and and
it works in simple ways that we don't
even talk about but it's so simple you
cross the street five minutes later a
bus drives down the street you just say
oh my gosh I was old I was almost hit
you
oh you're a bit of a drama queen you
know that right
but wait a minute when someone's hit by
a bus
what now it came back
Minnesota
just barreling down this it was in the
same spot
there I could have died
right you would not have died and by the
way in relativity we call these World
lines your world line is where you are
in space and time
which is always in motion right because
time as a even if you're sitting there
on your butt right you're moving forward
in time
by the way this affects time machines
all right and so I give you a time
machine and you say okay you want to go
um uh into the future how far do you
want to go in the future well I'm gonna
go at least 200 years just to see if
we're still here okay but suppose you
say all right I don't want to land in
the winter let me land in the summer so
I want to go 200 years in six months
okay okay let's think because we're
recording this it's cold outside right
now right so you do that all right so
you go go on your time machine go 200
years and then you walk out of the time
machine you will suffocate in the vacuum
of space
it's
moving while it's spinning okay so you
will land in the same spot that Earth
was in its orbit which is a different
place than where it is six months from
now
oh man which tells you a time machine
can only work if it's a space-time
machine that's right
that's pretty awesome you want to move
to a location in time and a location in
space correct right
all right so
oh wow that is really cool because okay
so now why yeah watch how this plays out
are we are we on the same page now
until I hear Neil I'm with you I am
riding this wave with you buddy okay
okay so
um under normal circumstances I'm in my
office three or four days a week I
travel a lot
um there are seminars in colloquia
scientists come through to the
department and they give talks you know
if I'm around I'm going to attend those
talks because they're good they learn
about the latest breaking discoveries
made by my colleagues okay so we get we
have maybe three or four talks a week in
our division at the American Museum of
Natural History and used to make maybe
one of those a week all righty
however
during covid
I was making four out of four talks a
week
okay
because Zoom calls
broke the space-time Alliance
so that now you only have to be at the
same time and you do not have to be at
the same place
interesting as a result World lines can
split and only conjoin on the time
coordinate rendering the space
coordinate irrelevant
um but that is why probably more people
attending more conferences seeing more
meetings than ever before
you can no longer use an excuse oh I'm
on a on a business trip I can't come and
zoom in
we have you on the zoom call
I know it's an electronic lease is what
it is for most people and that's how
Chuck you spent how many months you were
filming brain games for National
Geographic you're the new host in their
new season yet you didn't lose a bit of
this schedule your background was
different because you were recording
with us via Zoom through your hotel
rooms and other setups that's right and
so so we you were still participating
because your world line didn't need the
space coordinate that's true and so this
is the relationship between Zoom calls
and Einstein's theory of relativity
that is a that's pretty wild and
um in a way I have a new respect for
Zoom now uh for breaking the steps
space-time Continuum yes exactly it's
like who knew Zoom was so damn sci-fi
[Laughter]
yeah I love it no in all fairness to
prior means of communicating that
predates Zoom the telephone was kind of
like that yeah all right and by the way
do you know what the word caller meant
before there's a telephone
uh it was a visitor to you front to your
front I was gonna say
um a handsome gentleman perhaps yeah you
have a gentleman caller oh I do believe
you have a gentleman caller yes exactly
that's the meaning of that with the
original meaning of that word and then
Alexander Bell invents a telephone and
so what word are you going to use when
you show up at the front door of the
telephone line
it's a caller it's a caller and now
that's we've been that way for a hundred
and you know 30 years or whatever so we
in 150 years now so 1876 was the
demonstration of the patent for the
first telephone
um and so that put people together in
time without having to be together in
space wow
so so this is what this is like one of
the great achievements and advances in
modern civilization
uh and zoom just did it full up with
voice and sound and audio quality and
saved files and everything hey
because the video call was purported to
be the thing that would change
everything in society I remember seeing
a video phone in 1964 World's Fair in
New York wow wow that's the future and
then you realize you called someone at
six in the morning they don't want you
looking at there yeah exactly
the people don't always want you looking
at them anytime you happen to call them
what is that on your face don't look at
my face
let's just have a call stop looking at
so now you can pre-schedule zoom calls
and now you can get all dolled up and
look a little dirty Zoom party yeah you
got to that's pretty yeah that's great
though I mean it's it's who knew that
you could link this back to Einstein I
said you had a a tough one but you did
it you linked it back to Einstein
somehow and now you know with asteroids
we're just changing his world line yeah
but by the way that is the coolest thing
ever the fact that I mean you and the
idea is you don't even have to knock it
off course you can just speed it up or
slow it down that's because you always
think of deflection as a change in going
sideways in the projector right right
well a vector is direction and speed and
speed technically a vector has both of
those components so if you change this
direction or you change the station
change its velocity the velocity is the
combination of those two so it's exactly
so it's that's great it's like that I
mean I am less scared of asteroids now
still be scared I don't want that was
not the point of this to explain oh okay
by the way a velocity Vector is motion
that has Direction and and and speed as
part of it like the asteroid right right
so you can change this direction or
change its speed uh or both
either of those are changing the
velocity of the asteroid okay so now
watch you can do that so with a car
there are three ways to change this
velocity
right you can slow it down you can speed
it up and you can hit a wall or another
car
ideally not okay you can slow down that
reduces its speed you can accelerate
increase its speed or
you can change direction okay
all three of those
can help you avoid an accident right
it's not just how good your brakes are
do you have a place to steer
so that your world line does not fully
intersect with the one that would cause
the accident uh you know what as a
person who rides a motorcycle you just
explain how you stay alive on a bike
those are the three things that are your
friend that they teach you all the time
the first is acceleration get up and get
out of the way the second is being able
to break properly but now motorcycles
have anti-lock brakes so that used to be
a big deal not so much but the most
important is being able to maneuver so
you know to to be able to particularly
Nimble in that regard exactly right yeah
right super cool so Chuck we got to
bring this to a close this was stuck if
you thought you knew yeah and now I do
[Music]
and the inventory was rainbows zero and
zoom calls and relativity there it is
yeah that says this is Motley a crew as
you find I was gonna say strange bed
Falls but hey it works all right Chuck
we're gonna Land This Plane and I'm
gonna get out and so are you
Neil deGrasse Tyson here you're a
personal astrophysic wait a minute wait
a minute before I end
I did say it didn't I
Chuck your show premiered for with
National Geographic yes that's a new
host oh my gosh yes yes please watch it
people
don't sound that desperate chuck oh yeah
that's right that's not the way you're
not supposed to uh not supposed to um
promote a show back on hey man please
watch it I got kids
[Laughter]
hey man
please watch my show
no brain games it's a new season 20
episode just dropped on uh National
Geographic you can get it through the
Disney portal that's correct and uh
check out our very own Chuck Nice we we
take present we take ownership of You
Chuck we feel like you're ours that's
right yeah well that's what I don't I
don't I feel that way too okay
thank you yeah thanks Neil all right all
right this has been Star Talk Neil
deGrasse Tyson here as always keep
looking up
[Music]